with marketing stunts like this and this
transferwise is hard to ignore the
international money transfers startup is
one of London's few unicorns and it's
trying to shake up how money moves
across the globe transferwise is all
about bashing the bank's how much they
charge what exchange rates they use for
every thousand pounds you transfer we
take fifty the company says it's
different but now the party's over
it promises to make transfers a whole
lot cheaper and easier than the VAX
and here's how money never actually
crosses any borders so I have pounds but
I want to send dollars to my mate in New
York rather than wiring the money
internationally transfer wise uses
algorithms to try to find another
pairing trying to send money in the
other direction it locks on to Jake in
California he has dollars but wants to
send pounds to his sister in the UK so
my friend gets Jake's dollars and his
sister gets my pounds because no funds
are converted into other currencies in
theory everyone saves money half a
billion pounds crosses the platform
every month it's responsible for 5% of
all international transfers from the UK
and since it came to the u.s. it's
processed more than two billion dollars
big time investors are taking notice
transfer wise just raised another 26
million dollars in funding and that adds
to early investment from legendry PC
firm Andris and Horowitz Richard Branson
Peter Thiel and others but not everyone
thinks transfer wise represents good
value despite the huge transaction
volumes the company just isn't
profitable and detractors say it's
hardly reinventing the wheel while 60%
of its transactions are peer-to-peer the
company funds the rest with its own
money which isn't that different to what
Western unions been doing for a century
transferwise argues saving people money
is revolutionary in itself
maybe the company's biggest innovation
is the promise not to screw its
customers